tomorrow 33 000 runners are set to make
their way through the streets of all
five new york city boroughs competing in
the 50th annual new york city marathon
but for one man the day will mark an
accomplishment even greater than
completing the 26.2 mile course for tom
mcgrath a beloved owner of manhattan's
black sheep bar and long time charitable
runner it will be another step forward
on a life-saving journey
time is a concept running alongside tom
mcgrath on thursday in central park was
just a glimpse into his road ahead am i
slowing you no no no
so what's what's the plan for you well
it's actually one day at a time dinner
the 71 year old is on course to hit 100
miles in four days time when he crosses
the finish line of sunday's new york
city marathon in an effort to raise
money for the tunnel to towers
foundation they do amazing work for
the people that served our country yeah
that fought for america last month in
mcgrath's east side bar the black sheep
we sat down to talk i was deployed to
afghanistan he told me one of the
foundation's commercials struck a cord a
veteran describing his daily struggle it
was hard having everybody change her
lifestyle to take care of me he said the
hardest thing that he had to do
was call his children
to pick him off the bathroom floor
he wasn't able to get off the floor
that hurt me
deep down as many as a time i called my
wife and daughter to pick me off the
bathroom floor
but i was drunk
he fought for our country
what a difference
mcgrath is a recovering alcoholic his
constant tug of war between his battle
with alcoholism and his love of running
is detailed in a new documentary saved
by my feet
[Music]
mcgrath gained international fame as an
ultrarunner
today the 27 year old bar owner set off
to break the world's longest and
stalking record in 1977 he crossed the
u.s in a record 53 days seven minutes
and a few years later ran his irish
homeland in seven days different feet
like giving in every five minutes
over time the alcohol won out i know as
many as the morning even here in this
bar that i'd be standing here by myself
maybe at six o'clock and seven o'clock
in the morning not gone home yet and i'd
see joggers going by the window that
would break my heart
i knew i was doing wrong i really knew
deep down
in my heart and soul i knew i should be
out there on the road in 2010 doctors
told mcgrath he had a week to live his
liver was failing my daughter said to me
dad your eyes are yellow my wife said to
me
don't die on me that's a heavy statement
it didn't register with me that's part
of being an alcoholic drinking what he
estimates was a quart a day at the time
mcgrath says it was the words of his
doctor that finally got through he says
the next fall you take
could be your last
you won't come off the ground they'll
put your six foot under
is that the way you want to end your
life
and i looked at the
the next fall
you take
what could be your last fall you won't
get off the ground
that is a major part of my recovery
there
part of mcgrath's journey to sobriety
included a return to running he was
determined to use his athletic ability
to help more than just himself
come on come on
running for charity when you run long
distance like i do the body gets tired
the muscles get sore and the mind gets
weak but you're helping somebody think
of those kids that i was running for and
they don't know what the word is to give
up because they're fighting to live and
you think of them i can't stop now
it's estimated that mcgrath has run
upwards of 200 000 miles even earning an
unforgettable nickname now just entering
the stadium is an irish man who has been
dubbed the real-life forest gump
is it trading
one addiction in a sense for another
well
i like that
a much healthier addiction calling
running at addiction yes when i get up
in the morning i'm planning the next
day's run yeah not today i'm planning
tomorrow
maybe a wee bit of an addiction yeah but
it's a good one
and it's why he's still running despite
a year which could have easily sent
mcgrath back to the bottle one which
included the pandemic and his wife's
lung cancer diagnosis
business was closed my wife's in
hospital diagnosed with cancer
no business no money no nothing coming
in
and
running then
was put in the back burner my hundred
mile run was still in my head
and i couldn't tell anybody just myself
and the man above
i couldn't tell anybody because
you can't go away running and leave your
wife
with cancer to defend for herself
so
it was one hell of a year for not just
me but for the whole world actually for
you though in what you have gone through
will this run do you think feel
sweeter different oh yeah
absolutely yeah this is the run of my
life
it is beautiful here yeah
you told me a few weeks ago that this
was
going to be the run of your life yeah
started and it finished i know god's
good
if he's in charge from here on end
i cannot say enough about this man and
how inspiring his story is i should say
that you can find his documentary on
youtube and itunes right now but man
he's out there running right now i'm
sure he's out there running right now
he's got to get his miles up so tomorrow
he does his 26.2 it's amazing and then
the 26.2 is the last is the last the
last portion of 100 exactly and his wife
is out there and she's his wife is not
there with him his wife is still
battling cancer right now i asked how
she's doing and he said okay sort of a
funny note he said she doesn't quite
know how much he's running right now she
knows he went to do a charity run he
said to me she might find out from
watching your show i don't know but
she'll find out after that i did the
hundred miles rudiment rudemont as we
all are thank you dana well